this video is brought to you by bespoke post
bespoke post is a monthly membership club
delivering amazing boxes of top shelf goods from
under the radar brands every month bespoke post
introduces its members to cool new products
outdoor gear bar wear home and kitchen goods
clothing then a lot more this is all based on
a preference quiz that they fill out it's free
to join and you can skip a month anytime this is
one example of the things they send out in their
boxes this was from the weekender box and it is a
just pull back a little bit here it's a fantastic
weekend bag made out of this great canvas material
reinforced it's got this metal in here just feels
very very strong very very good each box has about
70 dollars in retail value because it's only 45
and you can preview the box before it ships
out and decide if you want to keep it swap it
or skip the month for no charge bespoke box lineup
is constantly changing every month and it's great
for you but also a great gift too this was the
brew box can you guys see this beer making kit
obviously says it right there on the front makes a
nice ipa everything you need is in the box there's
all of the uh what is beer made from i don't even
know uh then this giant glass bottle there's all
the tubing there's a whole bunch of stuff in
there that you will need right now you guys
can get 20 off your first box by going to bspk dot
me forward slash biographics 20 or just clicking
the link in the description below and entering
biographics 20 at checkout and now today's video
new york assistant district attorney
abraham rock described fritz duken
as one most desperate and daring criminals
we've ever had here his adventures read
like a romance daily mail to cry to ken as
a notorious scoundrel wanted for murder on
the high seas the sinking and burning of british
ships the burning of military stores warehouses
coaling stations conspiracy the falsification
of admiralty documents and that's just the
cliff notes version de ken started off as a big
game hunter in africa then he became a commando
during the bar war responsible for countless
assassinations that earned in the moniker of
the black panther of the beld then in the first
world war he turned saboteur responsible for
the bombing of several ships and finally in
world war ii he established powerful spyring
to help out nazi germany he did all this to
torment great britain to put it simply there
was nothing that taken would not do in order to
persecute the british find out what motivated his
undying hatred as we take a look at the life of
a man whose exploits read like something plucked
out of the pages of a pulp magazine this is the
story of the south african adventurer fritz de ken
frederick fritz zhuber ducan was born on september
21 1877 in east london not the one in england but
rather the city on the southeastern coast of
south africa it was located in what was back then
a self-governing british colony called
cape colony his parents abraham ducan and
minaju bear were bowers referring to south
africans descended from european settlers in
their case both had french huguenot ancestry fritz
said that his mother was related to piet jubei the
commandant general of the south african republic
and a war hero to the boers but then again fritz
said a lot of things throughout his life the man
spent decades in numerous careers using dozens of
fake identities and making countless incredible
and unsubstantiated claims knowing exactly
which ones were true and which ones were false
became an almost impossible task that not even
his biographers could pull off anyway when fritz
was young his family moved to nielstron today
the town of moromol in south africa where they
purchased a farm this was in the south african
republic which at the time was an independent
state the household consisted of fritz his parents
his two younger siblings isbet and pedro and their
great uncle yarn abraham de ken worked as a farmer
hunter and trader and took fritz along on hunting
trips from an early age teaching him valuable
survival and killing skills out in the african
veil when he was only 12 years old fritz killed
his first man in self-defense the family used the
main room of their house as a trading post and
one day while abraham was away a zulu customer
got into an argument with fritz's mom over the
prices when he became violent prince rushed him
grabbed the man's zatagai spear and stabbed him
through the stomach the following year 13 year
old fritz went to school in england he studied
civil engineering after graduation and joined
up with a con man named christian devries and
started traveling around the world swindling
people from town to town his father found out
about this and put a stop to it when he finally
caught up with fritz in singapore the young man
spent a few more carefree years just lounging
around europe but the easy times would soon end
forever in 1899 the 21 year old had to return to
his home in south africa where he developed his
fanatical hatred of the british that
would dominate the rest of his life
in 1899 the second bear war erupted between the
united kingdom and two independent bow estates
called the south african republic and the orange
free state ostensibly the causes for the war were
varied and complex as the conflict had been
brewing for almost a century but realistically
it all boiled down to gold and diamonds the boers
had them and the british wanted them as you could
tell from the name there was also a first burr war
back in 1880 however that was a relatively quick
affair that lasted only three months resulting in
a boer victory with only a few hundred casualties
by comparison the second boer war was longer and
much much more brutal as the british employed
scorched earth policies and concentration camps
to counter the guerrilla warfare used by the boers
although decan had made england his adopted home
he did not hesitate to return and fight for the
south african republic soon after joining the
war he took part in the siege of lady smith in
november 1899 where he received a gunshot wound to
the shoulder followed by a promotion to artillery
captain the injury couldn't keep down for long
though and by december he had healed enough
to fight in the battle of calenso where he was
taken prisoner for the first time this did not
prove to be much of an obstacle for decan as he
turned out to be a master escape artist pw camps
could hardly contain him and he was captured
several times but he always managed to get away
during a return trip to the farm where he grew up
tiken discovered the gruesome fate that befell his
family at the hands of the british army the whole
place had been burned to the ground his sister had
been raped and shot in the back his uncle left
a hang from a telegraph pole and his mother had
been kidnapped and sent to a concentration camp
this was the pivotal moment that changed his life
forever the moment that fritz de ken decided
to spend the rest of his years inflicting
as much pain and as much suffering as possible on
great britain and its people his greatest hatred
was reserved for general herbert kitchener who
was the commander-in-chief of the british forces
in the burr war and was the one who enacted the
ruthless scorched earth policy decline discovered
that his survival skills made it perfect
for guerrilla warfare and soon enough he
was leading his own commando unit responsible for
a great deal of sabotage explosions and stealthy
assassinations his ability to strike without
being seen earned ken the nickname the black
panther of the veld and he soon turned into public
enemy number one for the british who wanted him
dead and buried they even tasked one of their best
scouts american officer frederick russell burnham
to track down and kill fritz burnham failed
to do so and later described his experience
in his memoirs he said there were only two men
on the belt i feared and one was to ken much has
been written about to ken most of it rubbish
yet his real accomplishments were so terrible
they make the yellow journal thrillers about him
seem as mild as radio bedtime stories he was the
greatest scout the buzz produced he was one of
the craftiest men i ever met he had something of
a genius of the apache for avoiding combat except
in his own terms yet he will be the last man i
should choose to meet in a dark room for a fight
to the finish armed only with knives around this
time we get arguably the most popular legend
which involved duquesne that of his notorious
krug millions the story goes that the president
of the south african republic paul kruger had a
gigantic horde of gold shipped out of the capital
to a safe location to avoid having it fall into
british hands with decan in charge of one of the
shipments while passing through portuguese east
africa or mozambique as we call it today the other
soldiers tried to double-cross again and steal the
gold for themselves the fight ensued where de ken
once again proved why he deserved his fearsome
reputation he killed them all and had the porters
hide the gold somewhere safe but never returned
to recover it since then the legend of the kruger
millions has spread far and wide and many people
have spent years searching for this lost treasure
de ken eventually made his way to the front lines
again and took part in the battle of bergendahl
in august 1900. this ended up being the last
pitched battle of the war even though the conflict
continued for two more years following another
british victory ducan and his men had to retreat
into mozambique brits was captured again and sent
to an intern camp near lisbon but just like before
this was just a small detour for him duken escaped
again this time by allegedly seducing the daughter
of one of the guards from this point on we can
honestly say that ken embraced his new career as
a spy and saboteur as a man with a dozen different
identities who would never go back to the simple
life he once had in the grasslands of africa
after he fled portugal de ken did not return to
south africa instead he did something incredibly
ballsy even for him he marched straight into
the belly of the beast traveling to england
and joining the british army we're not
sure how exactly he pulled it off but
thanks to his school year spent in britain he
had lost his south african accent and instead
sounded like a posh englishman some say he simply
presented himself as a bird effector others think
that fritz had fake papers and used them to
craft a new identity for himself but anyway
in 1901 de ken returned to cape town this time as
an officer with the british forces some accounts
say that ken used his british credentials to track
down the location of the concentration camp where
his mother was held he went there and he found her
half dead starving and infected with syphilis from
repeated sexual assaults he couldn't just walk
her out without raising questions so he had to
leave her behind knowing that he would never see
her again diken temporarily satiated his lust for
revenge by killing two british captains that he
passed on his way out of the camp assuming that
any of that actually happened ken then spent some
time building up a network of bur sympathizers and
developing a list of valuable targets to destroy
as much as he enjoyed spilling british blood he
probably realized that he could do more damage by
blowing up bridges munition dumps power plants and
things like that however he never acted
on his plans because he was betrayed by
one of his co-conspirators and the entire network
was arrested everybody else was sentenced to death
and executed but fritz avoided his date with
the firing squad by supplying the english with
secret bower codes for communication later to ken
always insisted that the codes he provided to the
enemy were fake but for now he found himself
imprisoned in a 17th century dutch ford called
the castle of good hope unsurprisingly he
immediately went to work on his escape and
he intended to dig out the stones using a spoon
his plan was discovered though so ducan was
sent to a penal colony in bermuda that had
been repurposed as a pow camp for the buzz
this time fritz did not make it out so easily it
wasn't until june 1902 that he managed to escape
the island and secure passage on a ship with the
help of members from the bar relief committee
by this point the war was over with a decisive
victory for the british but this did nothing to
diminish the hatred that de ken still felt in his
heart however there was nothing and no body left
for him in south africa so instead he sailed
to america to start a new life in the u.s de
ken landed in maryland and then made his way to
new york city he still wanted to get revenge on
the british but now that the war had ended there
wasn't much demand for sabotage or commando work
instead he needed to divide his time and
wait for the right opportunity to come along
until then ken needed a job and found employment
with the new york herald at first he was simply
a bill collector but his knife-edged stories of
hunting and adventuring out in the wilds of africa
proved popular enough that ken was hired as a
contributing writer he was then made a regular
reporter and by 1906 he was the sunday editor
for the herald undoubtedly like all other things
in his life deken's exploits out in the world
had been heavily sensationalized but they found
a captive audience which included one hunting
enthusiast named teddy roosevelt who happened
to be president of the united states at the time
roosevelt's admiration scored to ken an invitation
to the white house in 1909 where the two talked
big game hunting and fritz advised teddy on a
safari that he wanted to undertake so this is
the perfect time to mention the strangest moment
in dekken's career which for a man like fritz is
really saying something in 1910 he became one of
the driving forces behind a new movement taking
root in america to introduce the hippopotamus to
louisiana in response to a meat shortage de ken
testified as an expert before the committee of
agriculture and advocated for the importation not
only of the hippo but also other animals such as
the giraffe the yak the kudu the spring bark
and many others if decent and others had their
way today louisiana would be teeming with african
wildlife and you'd have to be on the lookout for
charging hippos while fishing in the mississippi
delta and if that's not weird enough one of the
other main proponents of the bill was frederick
russell burnham the same scout who had once been
tasked with tracking down and killing de
ken unfortunately the build did not pass
and louisiana remained hippo free when he
wasn't writing fritz traveled to war zones
as a correspondent and gave lectures around the
country he married a woman named alice wartley
in 1910 and became a naturalized american citizen
in 1913. the marriage lasted only eight years but
if he wanted deken could have still built
a really nice life for himself in america
if he could just let go of the past but his hatred
still consumed him so he jumped at the opportunity
to cause more chaos and suffering to the british
provided by the advent of the first world war
we don't know if tiken volunteered or was
recruited but it became a secret agent for germany
during world war one fritz had no particular ties
to the country prior to the war but going by the
old adage of the enemy of my enemy as my friend as
long as they fought the british that made them all
right in his book as a bonus slap in the face to
defend the famous british recruitment posters that
showed the mustachioed officer pointing a finger
saying stuff like your country needs you featured
none other than the country's new war minister the
man again hated more than any other person on the
planet lord kitchener de ken was mainly active
in south america during world war one sabotaging
ships on their way to britain he traveled from one
country to another and switched identities often
to avoid detection his basic strategy involved
sending boxes that were allegedly filled with
mineral samples and orchid bulbs back to england
but in reality the boxes were packed with timed
explosives which were set to detonate during their
forage across the atlantic deken bragged that he
sunk 22 ships using this method and while he
was certainly responsible for several explosions
that number is impossible to verify his coup
de grace came in february 1916 when de ken
set the ss tennyson on fire by placing on board a
trunk filled with highly flammable film celluloid
plus some explosives to ignite it adding insult to
injury fritz also tried to make some extra money
on the side by taking out an insurance policy on
the film which was a valuable commodity back then
his brazen gamble didn't pay off though and
he was discovered when he tried to cash it the
british now put a bounty on his head for the
death of three seamen aboard the tennyson but
de ken tried to evade it by faking his own death
in april 1916 newspapers around the world reported
a story that de ken had been killed while fighting
in bolivia the ruse only lasted for a few weeks as
he was spotted and recognized but the confusion
surrounding his untimely demise gave the burr
captain enough time to flee south america and
make it to europe we now arrive at de ken's most
boastful but also most doubtful claim that he was
the one who killed his arch-enemy lord kitchener
we know for a fact that lord kitchener died on
june 5th 1916. he was one of over 700 people
who perished when the hms hampshire hit a german
mine on its way to russia and sank in the cold
waters off the coast of scotland but according to
ken he was working with the germans on this hit
he said that he was on board the ship during that
fateful voyage disguised as a russian official and
that he dropped water torches over the side
the german u-boats would know where to plant
the mines he then jumped overboard into a waiting
raft and was collected by a submarine and taken
to germany where he received the iron cross no
german records survived to verify this claim so
maybe take this one with a grain of salt
whether or not that happens we can't say for
sure but deken eventually made his way back to
america except that he now styled himself as an
australian veteran named captain claude strawton
he kept the act going for a while but new york
authorities eventually found out his true identity
and arrested him in late 1917. this wasn't for any
of the bombings or assassinations mind you after
all america wasn't involved in the war when any
of those took place so they didn't really care
instead ken was indicted on insurance fraud for
trying to claim the losses he sustained following
the tennyson explosion he was also publicly outed
as a spy as he possessed a letter from the german
consul thanking him for rendering notable services
to our good german cause as you might imagine the
british really wanted to get their hands on him
and requested to be extradited to stantral for
murder while the whole process was being worked
out de ken tried a classic strategy feigning
insanity that might work in legal dramas but
it's surprisingly ineffective in real life and
nobody bought it after a few months he switched
up his tactic and collapsed in the middle of the
courtroom claiming to be paralyzed from the waist
down obviously everybody called shenanigans
but several doctors looked him over and
he passed all of their examinations he didn't
even flinch when one of them stuck needles
under his toenails ultimately people bought
the ruse and dukeen was sent to the prison
ward of a bellevue hospital what followed was
an oscar-worthy performance as fritz went full
method and spent the next few months in a
wheelchair pretending to be paralyzed at all
times but sawing through the bars of his cell
whenever he wasn't being watched on may 26 1919
only a few days before his extradition to britain
to stand trial for murder de ken made his escape
following his escape from bellevue fritz ken
remained a free man for the next 13 years this
part of his life remains poorly documented
he probably fled to mexico immediately after
leaving the u.s but we only know of his movements
for sure starting in the late 1920s he probably
should have avoided the united states altogether
given that he was a wanted man but fritz just
couldn't resist the glitz and glamour of new
york city so he returned under the new identity
of frank to trafford craven he found a job working
for businessman joseph p kennedy father of the
future president john f kennedy on the publicity
staff of his new production company rko studios
in 1932 ken got arrested again even though he
kept insisting that he was frank de trafford
craven his arrest was followed by a prolonged
and complicated trial that involve both the
u.s and britain syntax tradition can often turn
into a bureaucratic nightmare ultimately britain
decided that again just wasn't worth it so they
dropped the request once again fritz was a free
man with no legal troubles allowed to get on with
his life you'd think that the whole episode might
have encouraged him to live and let live but not
for it to ken when nazi germany came calling de
ken answered the call in 1937 fritz began working
for the ab there the german military intelligence
service and started developing a network of
spies you could either obtain valuable secrets
or carry out acts of sabotage all of this was
done with the foresight that eventually the united
states would go to war against germany by 1939
this network numbered over 30 people all placed
in key positions around the country and it became
known as the decans spy ring named after its
ringleader however it did not get a chance to do
any serious harm as the fbi broke up the spy ring
before america even joined the war as it turned
out one of the men inside the network was not that
keen on the nazis his name was william siebold
and even though he was born in germany he became
a naturalized american citizen and sided with his
adopted homeland he initially joined the spy ring
following pressure from high-ranking nazi members
while on a trip to germany but once he was back on
american soil he went to the fbi and told them
everything with his information the authorities
arrested duke and 32 other spies who were later
sentenced to a total of over 300 years in prison
for its tokens days of adventure chaos and
violence were officially over his trial occurred
shortly after the japanese bomb pearl harbor so
american sentiment was heavily against traitors
duquesne was sentenced to 18 years in prison and
served 12 before being released in 1954. by that
point he was an old broken man in poor health
following a stroke that left him partly paralyzed
he returned to new york city again or his place
in a nursing home on december 21 1955 de ken
gave a final speech at the adventurers club even
though many members refused to attend due to his
occasional bouts of treason it proved to be one
last chance for him to reminisce on the bloody
and daring exploits of his youth brits de ken died
of another stroke a few months later on the 24th
of may 1956 age 78 leaving behind a complicated
legacy some people saw him as a brave hero
others a villain and a madman some thought he was
an incredible adventurer while others decried him
as a fraudster and a liar some considered him
a cold-blooded murderer and others an agent
of righteous vengeance all his life fritz de ken
divided opinions and will probably continue to do
so for the foreseeable future so i really hope you
found this video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below don't forget to
subscribe and as always thank you for watching
you